in today's morning rounds a warning
about panic buying over the coronavirus
the World Health Organization says
people are snapping up medical supplies
and that could put health care workers
at risk the outbreak caused a run on
surgical style masks and hand sanitizers
and other preventative items but is all
that really necessary
Motul ng spent the day inside a Georgia
production production facility to find
out how people's response to the virus
is stressing the supply chain the floor
here at Mehta comms Augusta Georgia
Factory is buzzing they're working
nearly around the clock to fill demand
[Music]
protective masks of every kind are
flying off store shelves around the
country including a run on hand
sanitizer his fears of a spreading
coronavirus have catapulted sales of
protective medical supplies Keon
Labrador is the chief operating officer
of Medicom a global supplier of
infection control products what sort of
numbers in terms of increase have you
seen here at your plants we can't cope
with the demand the demand is multiplied
by 510 it's just just out of any
proportion that we've seen in the past
this Factory is moving as briskly as it
can but it might not be fast enough to
keep up with a nervous public's appetite
we don't recommend them for the general
public denver health chief medical
officer and infectious disease
researcher dr. connie support price says
the dwindling mask supply is worrisome i
am concerned about our hospital
facilities and our ability to deliver
continued care not only for coronavirus
but other routine illnesses a standard
surgical mask is effective at resisting
large airborne droplets or other fluids
but it's not designed to filter viruses
it's loose fit also makes it easier for
droplets to enter around the edges of
the mask the n95 respirator is an
upgrade a tight custom fitted mask that
forces inhaled air toward the masks body
and not its edges it's capable of
filtering out 95% of particulates
including small droplets but not viral
particles in fact it could have the
alternative undesired effect of
transmitting these infections more
readily to the untrained where there's
no role for these masks in the community
despite pleas from public health
officials for every day New Yorkers
there's no need to use a mask panic
buying of surgical masks seems to
continue and this struggle to meet the
demand is not specific to your company
it's industry-wide it's all over the
industry in all over the countries so we
have a factory in France where
everything exactly the same challenge
for CBS this morning
Moeller leggy Augusta Georgia thank you
very much now let your co-anchors tell
you you do not need a mask but you might
want to be met by masks futures